CONGRATULATIONS, MR. TRIPLE-
DOUBLE!
>> MR. TRIPLE-DOUBLE HIMSELF!
>> RUSSELL WESTBROOK!
>> WE COULDN'T BE HAPPIER THAT
YOU'RE A WASHINGTON WIZARD,
RUI, AND SO HAPPY THAT YOU'VE
EMBRACED OUR FANS AND OUR CITY,
AND THEY'VE EMBRACED YOU RIGHT
BACK.
ON BEHALF OF THE WASHINGTON
WIZARDS ORGANIZATION, THANK
YOU!
CONGRATULATIONS!
WE WOULD LIKE TO PRESENT YOU
WITH A COMMEMORATIVE WIZARDS
JERSEY TO KEEP AND REMIND YOU
OF THE MOMENT YOU MADE A
STATEMENT AND REWROTE HISTORY!
AFTER ALL, WHY NOT YOU, RUSS?
MR. LEONSIS, PLEASE PRESENT THE
JERSEY TO MR. TRIPLE-DOUBLE!
D.C. FAMILY, LET'S MAKE SOME
NOISE FOR YOUR ALL-TIME TRIPLE-
DOUBLE LEADER, RUSSELL
WESTBROOK!